HEHE H HASAS D DUNUNKIMIMS S BE.
HEHERERE I IT T ISIS..
>>>> O OKAKAY.Y.
>>>> I I D DUNUNKEKED D WIWITHTG
TITIMEME I IN N THTHE E SESEASA.
HEHE I ISS  SMSMARART,T, H HEE .
YOYOU'U'VEVE G GOTOT T TOO P PA.
I I AMAM G GOIOINGNG T TO O FOFN
HEHE G GOTOT I IT.T. H H E EIGI
>>>> H HEE C CANAN G GETET A AN.
THTHEREREE Y YOUOU T THAHATT R T
AWAWAYAY. .
>>>> G GAMAMEE
DUDUNKNKERER. .
>>>> J JALALENEN G GREREENEN..
THTHERERE E YOYOU U GOGO..
>>>> M MOROREE L LIKIKEE D DISI
>>>> I I G GOTOT A A D DONONUTU
>>>> H HEE S SHOHOULULD D HAHAV
>>>>>> T THAHAT'T'S S A A GOGOO
>>>> O OH!H! J JUAUAN N TOTOSCS
>>>> L LOVOVE.E.>>>> W WININDMD
HEHERERE..
WIWINDNDMIMILLLL O OFFFF T THEH
>>>> T THAHANKNK Y YOUOU. .
>>>> T THAHATT W WASAS NINICEC
>>>> H HEE W WASAS N NOTOT G GO
>>>> MAMAN,N, P PLELEASASE.E.
>>>> I I K KNONOWW T TENENEN E
BOBOARARD.D.
>>>> I I D DONON'T'T W WANANTT
>>>> H HE E HAHASS A ABOBORTRTE
>>>> B BETETWEWEENEN T THEHE L !
ANANDD Y YOUOU W WILILL L WIWIN
>>>> I I N NEVEVERER W WONON W I
>>>> R RIGIGHTHT N NOWOW..
>>>> O OH,H, Y YEAEAH.H.
>>>> M MARARQUQUETETTETE.. W WO
>>>> I I W WOUOULDLD J JUSUSTT -
BRBRINING G ITIT A ALLLL T TOGO.
NENEWW Y YORORK,K, T THEHE G GO
>>>> H HEE W WININ..
THTHEREREE M MIGIGHTHT N NOTOT
>>>> A A W WANANT T TOTO B BEE
>>>> Y YOUOU W WANANTT T T